[موسيقى]
صحيح ان النظام الدستوري في اوكرانيا هو
نظام اقرب الى الرئاسه حيث رئيس الجمهوريه
هو رئيس الدوله وهو من يقترح اسم رئيس
الوزراء الذي يصادق البرلمان على تعيينه
وصحيح اكثر ان رئيس الوزراء يقترح اسماء
كل وزرائه باستثناء وزيرين هما الخارجيه
والدفاع يختارهما رئيس الجمهوريه للتاكيد
على رئاسيه النظام في القضايا السياسيه
لكن الواقع في اوكرانيا مختلف بعض الشيء
فعلى مدى 32 عاما منذ استقلال اوكرانيا
الحديث لعب رؤساء الوزراء ادوار رئيسيه
واساسيه ومفصليه اما اليوم فكل الدوله
مجنده من رئاسه مجلس الوزراء وكافه
المؤسسات بعد الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
كلها مسؤوله وكلها معباه سياسيا
ودبلوماسيا وحياتيا وعسكريا لهذا اللقاء
اليوم مع رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ضروري
للكلام عام من حرب اوكرانيا لنفهم ماذا
حصل خلال هذا العام الصعب في تاريخ
اوكرانيا الحديث عن الفساد عن السياسه عن
العلاقات الخارجيه والقضايا المفصليه اهلا
بك رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني لاول مره باول
ظهور على شاشه عربيه بهذه المقابله بعد
سنه من الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه سابدا
السؤال بعد سنه من الحرب انتم تطالبون
بفرض عقوبات جديده على روسيا اتحدث هنا عن
قطاع المعادن عن القطاع النووي وعن
الالماس هل هناك تجاوب من الجانب الامريكي
والاوروبي خصوصا ان هناك يعني وجهات نظر
مختلفه حول هذا الموضوع
شكرا لك على اتاحه الفرصه لاجراء محادثه
مع اليوم ليس من الناحيه العسكريه او
الماليه لكن ايضا دعم العقوبات مهم للغايه
بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا وبالطبع نجري حوارا
مثمرا الغايه مع شركائنا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده والدول الشركه
الاخرى التي تنضم بشان زياده ضغط العقوبات
على روسيا كما نعلم ان اوروبا تبنت بالفعل
احدى عشره حزمه من العقوبات ونطلب من
شركائنا فرض عقوبات على الصناعه النوويه
الروسيه وعلى صناعه تعدين الماس وايضا
عقوبات شخصيه وفرديه على السياسيين الروس
ومديريه تلك الشركات المتعلقه بتمويل
الحرب في اوكرانيا لماذا تعد العقوبات
مهمه من المهم جدا التاكيد ان العقوبات لا
تمنح روسيا فرصه لملء الميزانيه التي تمول
من خلالها العدوان المسلح هذه الحرب
الدمويه في الواقع حرب ارهابيه واباده
جماعيه للشعب الاوكراني والعقوبات ايضا لا
تسمح لروسيا بالتزويد بالمعدات
التكنولوجيه الحديثه التي تسمح ايضا
بانتاج الاسلحه التي يقتلون بها
الاوكرانيين انتم تعولون على الدعم
الامريكي والاوروبي بهذا الموضوع وكان
هناك زياره لرئيس بايدن الى اوكرانيا
وايضا اليوم كان هناك يعني مفادين
امريكيين دائما يزورون هنا وايضا اوروبيين
الى اي ماده تعولون على الدعم الامريكي
بالتحديد بهذا الموضوع بموضوع العقوبات
ولماذا التردد الاوروبي بفرض مزيد من
العقوبات على روسيا
يجب القول ان القضيه فرض العقوبات لها
جانبان دائما الجانب الاول هو اضعاف قدره
المعتدي روسيا علشان مثل هذه الحرب
والجانب الاخر للعقوبات هو التقرير
تاثيرها السلبي على الدول في الحصول على
المعدات اللازمه في الصناعات العسكريه من
الدول الغربيه والبحث عن هذا الحل الوسط
هو ما يدور حوله الحوار الداخلي في الدول
الاوروبيه بين دول مجموعه السبع ومجموعه
العشرين من المهم بالنسبه الينا ان نفهم
ان العقوبات تلعب دورها الرئيسي في الواقع
واضعاف روسيا ومنعها من انتاج وتمويل
اسلحه جديده لقتل الاوكرانيين وهذا هو
الهدف الاساسي بالطبع عندما يعتمد بلد او
اخر بشكل كبير على النفط والغاز والوقود
النووي من روسيا يمكن لهذه الدول بالطبع
مناقشه فاعليه اثار العقوبات وهنا يجب على
المرء ان يبحث فقط عن النهج الصحيح لفرض
العقوبات والبلدان التي لديها اعتماد على
روسيا والابتعاد عن الغاز والنفط الروسي
احيانا يستغرق قدرا معينا من الوقت ويسبب
بالفعل مشكلات ومناقشات
ايضا بالدعم السياسي كان هناك زياره لم
وفد من المملكه العربيه السعوديه برئاسه
وزير الخارجيه السعودي اتى الى اوكرانيا
وهناك يعني
مالي وانساني للجانب الاوكراني الى اي مدى
تعولون على الدعم العربي اليوم وتحديدا
دعم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
للغايه لدول الخليج لدعمها اوكرانيا على
دعمها السياسي في الواقع دول الخليج تدعم
جميع القرارات في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده فهي تدعم جميع القرارات السياسيه
دعنا نقل قرارات اوكرانيا والشركاء نحن
نقدر ذلك ونحن ممتنون لها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تنفذها بشكل منفصل وهي رائده في
تنفيذ الدعم الانساني لاوكرانيا تم تخصيص
اكثر من 410 ملايين دولار خصيصا للدعم
الاجتماعي الانساني للاوكرانيين هذه هي
الاكبر في الاستثمار بين دول الخليج في
دعم المشروعات الانسانيه والاجتماعيه في
اوكرانيا اضافه الى ذلك
الامارات العربيه المتحده ايضا كما تقدم
دول الخليج الاخرى الدعم المناسب
لاوكرانيا ونحن نقدر ذلك بعمق ونشعر
بالامتناء
لدينا افاق جيده من حيث تطوير التعاون
التجاري والاقتصادي ونحن بالفعل ذو
الاهتماما لذلك بدءا من ديسمبر 2022 عندما
بدانا مفاوضات التعزيز التعاون الاقتصادي
ندع دول الخليج للمشاركه في مشروعات
المستقبل واعاده اعمار اوكرانيا بعد نهايه
هذه الحرب لدينا ايضا تعاون جيد جدا مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من حيث وضع
اتفاقيات تجاريه واقتصاديه جديده وكذلك
التعاون في الصداعه وفي جميع القطاعات من
الامن الغذائي الى التعاون التجاري في
مختلف قطاعات الاقتصاد ايضا من الملفات
المشتركه الاساسيه اليوم بين اوكرانيا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه هو موضوع تهديد
المسيرات او ما يعرف بالدرونز التي دمرت
معظم البنى التحتيه الاوكرانيه وتحديدا
انقطاع الكهرباء
التعاون العسكري
الايراني الى اي مدى اليوم هو خطر على
الواقع الاقليمي بالشرق الاوسط وايضا على
اوكرانيا وكم هي الخسائر التي تكبدها
الاقتصاد الاوكراني بسبب هذه المسيرات
تتطلب الحرب الحديثه بالتاكيد مقاربات
عاليه التقنيه وللاسف وجدت روسيا دعما في
شخص ايران فيما يتعلق بتزويد القوات
الروسيه بطائرات بدون طيار وللاسف تستخدم
روسيا هذه الطائرات بدون طيار ضد البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه وضد المدنيين قبل
مقابلتنا بقليل قصفت اربعه عشره طائره
ايرانيه بدون طيار البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
وقتل شخص واحد واصيب اربعه اليوم وهذا
مستمر منذ اكثر من نصف عام والمئات وربما
الالاف من الطائرات بدون الطيار الايرانيه
تقصف ايضا البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
والمدنيين في اوكرانيا وبطبيعه الحال
الاجراءات المضاده ضد هذه الطائرات بدون
طيار واستخدام نظائرها زادت بشكل كبير
بنسبه لاوكرانيا من حيث مواجهه هذا
العدوان غير المبرر لكنه عدوان وحشي لا
سيما ضد السكان المدنيين ضد المبادئ
الانسانيه وبالطبع دعم اوكرانيا من حيث
التصدير المعدات يمكن ان تصبح الطائرات
بدون طيار نقطه تحول حاسمه لذلك نحن
ممتنون لشركائنا وسنكون مرتنين للسعوديه
التي ستقدم مثل هذا الدعم لاوكرانيا
لزياده الضغط على ايران بحيث تتوقف ايران
عن امداد روسيا بالمعدات ذات الصله
والطائرات بدون
وهذه العمليه ستكون عاملا حاسما ورئيسيا
لمنع ايران من تصدير الصواريخ الى روسيا
التي ستستخدمها بالتاكيد لقتل المدنيين
الاوكرانيين
هل ستذهبون يعني الجهات الدوليه اتحدث هنا
عن المؤسسات الدوليه لمحاكمه ايران بقضايا
الجرائم الحرب ضد المدنيين بسبب هذه
المسيرات
نتحدث عن فتح محكمه دوليه ضد العدوان
الروسي ضد السياسيين الروس الذين اصدروا
اوامر جنائيه مماثله نتحدث ايضا عن حقيقه
ان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تحقق بالفعل
في جرائم جنائيه وجرائم حرب لروسيا يتحدث
عن حقيقه ان ايران حليف او متواطئ في
جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها روسيا بالتاكيد
في تحقيق الجنائي للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كجزء من تحقيق المحكمه العسكريه
الدوليه سنتحدث عن حقيقه ان ايران ساعدت
روسيا في ارتكاب هذه الجرائم بالاشهر
الاولى من الحرب تحدثتم عن ثمانين مليار
دولار لاعاده اعمار اوكرانيا اليوم بعد
سنه سنه من الحرب كم تحتاج اوكرانيا
لاعاده الاعمال
لسوء الحظ يواصل الروس تدمير البنيه
التحتيه في اوكرانيا وقد بلغ اجماليون فقط
اوكرانيا التي صاغها البنك الدولي اعتبارا
من الاول من يونيو
350 مليار دولار اعتبار من اليوم نحن على
يقين من انه قد تمت بالفعل مضاعفه المبلغ
وهذا ما يسمى برنامج التعافي السريع
للتعافي من الازمه التي تعصف بنا عندما لا
يكون هناك دعم من الممكن تقديم مجموعه
الحد الاد من الخدمات الانسانيه
والاجتماعيه لمواطنين وهذا مثل استعاده
امدادات الكهرباء وهذا هو ترميم المساكن
غير المدمره وترميم البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه وهذا هو ازاله الالغام وهو امر
مهم للغايه هذا هو دعم لاقتصاد الشركات
الصغيره والمتوسطه حتى يتمكن الناس من كسب
لقمه العيش وفقا للجدول واولويات الطبيعه
الاجتماعيه والانسانيه مهمه للغايه وتكلف
في الواقع ما يقارب 17 مليار دولار خلال
عام باكمله
[موسيقى]
كيف اثرت هذه الحرب على سلاسل الامداد
العالميه اتحدثون عن الغذاء والمواد
الاخرى التي تصدرها اوكرانيا القمح الزيت
كل المواد التي تصدرها اوكرانيا ويعتبر
حاجه اساسيه للعالم بالارقام
اوكرانيا واحده من اكبر مصدريه المنتجات
الغذائيه خاصه حبوب الذره وللاسف ادى
الحصار الذي فرضه الروس على الموانئ
البحريه الاوكرانيه الى واحده من اكبر
اجزامات الغذاء وهي ازمه الغذاء التي يمكن
ان تكون لها اثار ماساويه حقا في العديد
من البلدان الافريقيه والعديد من دول
الشرق الاوسط
لحسن الحظ تمكنا من تنظيم ممرات لوجستيه
عبر اوروبا وايضا عبر موانئ الدانوب وايضا
تنظيم ممر حبوب بشكل عام خلال هذا العام
من الحرب
صدرت اوكرانيا نحو 50 مليون طن من منتجات
الحبوب الغذائيه منها 21 مليون طن عبر
البحر الاسود رغم الحصار وصل الروس اغلاق
جزء كبير من موانئنا فقد ثلاثه موانئ كانت
تعمل لتصدير الحبوب فقط ثلاث سفن في اليوم
سمح لها الروس بالعبور عبر نقاط المتفق
عليها في تركيا واستطعنا تصدير حوالي 50
مليون طن اذا استقر الوضع في سوق المواد
الغذائيه بالطبع الان في شهر مارس ستكون
المرحله المقبله تنتهي بالماء البارد
ونطلب من جميع الشركاء خلق ضغط مناسب على
روسيا من اجل الاستمرار في ممر الحبوب حتى
لا يتسبب في المستقبل بازمه الحبوب
والغذاء
ايضا بالارقام كان انخفضه الصادرات بما ان
اوكرانيا ايضا لتصدر فقط الغذاء تصدر ايضا
المعادن كمنخفضه منذ بدايه الحرب حتى الان
يسمح منتجع الحبوب بتصدير الحبوب
والمنتجات الغذائيه فقط كما ان تصدير
المعادن من اوكرانيا امر معقد للغايه
واحجام التصدير تمثل حرفيا نسبه قليله من
التي كانت تصدر قبل الحرب بالطبع نحن
اليوم نبحث عن طرق لفتح الفرص لتصدير
المنتجات المعدنيه وغيرها من المنتجات من
اوكرانيا
تحتاجون اليوم للسنه الماليه في اوكرانيا
الى 40 مليار دولار انتم يعني تخطيتم
المرحله الاولى مع صندوق النقد عبر اقرار
البرنامج على مستوى الموظفين وفي الربيع
من المامول ان تبداوا برنامج البرنامج
الاقتصادي مع صندوق النقد ولكن هناك شروط
من قبل صندوق النقد شروط اصلاحيه هل
ستفرضون مزيد من الضرائب ويعني زياده
جبايه للضرائب وايضا شروط اصلاحيه اتحدث
عن مكافحه الفساد ماذا ستفعلون بهذين
الشرطين قبل ان انتقل للحديث عن الدول
المانحه
نحن اليوم نعمل بنشاط كبير مع صندوق النقد
الدولي لدعم اوكرانيا والبرنامج الجديد
لقد اكملنا مهمتنا لمراجعه برنامج
المراقبه وتولينا السلطه للعمل على برنامج
جديد مدته اربع سنوات وامنوا ان يصل الى
اكثر من خمسه عشر مليار دولار لمده اربع
سنوات تتكون من جزئين جزء سيوفر التمويل
اثناء الحرب والجزء الثاني سيوفر الدعم من
سكان اوكرانيا بالفعل في سياق الانتعاش
بعد الحرب وتنفيذ الاصلاحات الهيكليه في
اوكرانيا بالتاكيد مفاتيح اهتمامنا كحكومه
بشركائنا مع الدول الاجنبيه انها تكمن في
مكافحه الفساد فقد تم انشاء الاصلاحات
التي نكملها من خلال انشاء كل ما هو ضروري
لمعلم في اوكرانيا في مجال الرقمنه والذي
اصبح مستحيلا بسبب الفساد بشكل
عام لان الكمبيوتر لا ياخذ رشاوه نحن نتجه
نحو اقتصاد اكثر انفتاحا في السوق وبالطبع
نمر بالخصاصه من خلال انشاء مجالس اشراف
مناسبه من خلال اداره الشركات لافضل
المبادئ في منطقه عمل المنظمه الدوليه
للتعاون والتنميه على التوالي كل هذه
الخطوات تحظى بتقدير كبير اليوم من قبل
شركائنا
وانا مقتنع بانه رغم الحرب التي نواصلها
بنشاط سنواصل الاصلاحات فهذا هو طريقنا
الى العضويه الاوروبيه لنصبح عضوا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا هو الطريق الصحيح
لنصبح جزءا من الدول المتقدمه
هل الولايات المتحده طلبت منكم ان يعني
اختيار شخص مستقل يتمتع بالمصداقيه لمنصب
مدعي عام لمكافحه الفساد هل اخترتهم هذا
الشخص
اربعه اجهزه حكوميه في اوكرانيا الشرطه
والمخابرات ومكتب مكافحه الفساد ومحكمه
مكافحه الفساد وخلال شهر مارس سيتم تعيين
رئيس مكتب مكافحه الفساد في اوكرانيا تكمل
الاجهزه المعنيه التحقيقات في ملفات عده
وانا مقتنع بانه حتى النصف الاول من شهر
مارس ستكون الحكومه عينت رئيس المكتب
الوطني لمكافحه الفساد
الدول العربيه اليوم وتحديدا يعني بالدول
المانيحه الدول العربيه هي اساسيه كيف
يعني اليوم تخاطب هذه الدول خصوصا ان
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى دعم اقتصادي
والمرحله المقبله وبهذه المرحله ايضا وهو
ياتي بصلب برنامج صندوق النقد
هذا العام تحتاج اوكرانيا الى 47 مليار
دولار للتعافي السريع هذا مبلغ كبير
للغايه حتى اليوم لدينا دعم من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بمبلغ 18 مليار دولار من
البرنامج المالي ودول مجموعه السبع اضافه
الى اننا نعمل مع برنامج صندوق النقد
الدولي بالطبع يجب ان يصبح برنامج صندوق
النقد الدولي بمثابه دعامه هيكليه للدعم
الطويل الاجل
لانه نوع من المؤشرات وبرنامج الصندوق
النقد الدولي هو مؤشر على استقرار البلد
من حيث التنميه الاقتصاد الكلي واستقرار
الظروف العاديه له اهميه كبيره في
اقتصادنا فنحن نعمل معهم بنشاط كشركاء
وانا مقتنع باهميه العمل مع شركائنا
والبلدان التي دعمت اوكرانيا مثل الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون لدينا
مال الكافن للتعافي السريع
كيف تاثر قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
بالارقام بعد الضربات العسكريه الروسيه
لانها ركزت على تدمير البنيه التحتيه
وتحديدا انقطاع الطاقه يعني قبل الشتاء
وللعلم ان الشتاء اتى معاكس لاتوقعات
الروسيه
تاثير الحرب على قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
رئيسي احتل الروس محطه الطاقه النوويه
زابوريتشا وهي الاكبر في القاره الاوروبيه
حيث تمتلك السته مفاعلات نوويه من القوه
الاولى وهذه المحطه تشكل ربع اي 25% من
قدره اوكرانيا على توليد الطاقه قبل الحرب
الابتزاز النووي لاوروبا والعالم ياتي عبر
احتلال هذه المنشاه النوويه اضافه الى
التهديد بالصواريخ النوويه فضلا عن ان
الضربات بالمسيرات على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه دمرت نحو خمسه جيجا فولت من القدره
الاوكرانيه للطاقه اضافه الى ذلك تم تدمير
الشبكات الطاقه بالطبع فقدت اوكرانيا من
40 الى 50% من قدرتها على توليد الطاقه
لكن رغم ذلك بدعم الشركائنا تم تسليم
مولدات ومعدات جديده لذلك كنا قادرين على
اجتياز هذا الشتاء الصعب كان الروس ياملون
تهديد اوكرانيا بكارثه انسانيه عن طريق
الضربات الصاروخيه من البحر
لدعمنا اليوم في مجال ترميم واستقرار
الطاقه والتدفئه وامدادات الكهرباء هذه
واحده من الاولويات الرئيسيه في التعافي
السريع
شكرا لك رئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيه على هذه
المقابله على شاشه العربيه شكرا على
استضافه على وجودك معنا بهذه المقابله
نقدر تقديرا عاليا دعما ومساعده وتسهيل
جميع العمليات السياسيه من جانب دول
الخليج نشكر قياده وشعوب هذه الدول على
هذا الدعم الكبير ونشكركم على هذه
المقابله الرائعه
[موسيقى]